royal caribbean just announced more
fully vaccinated cruises
this year this time in the mediterranean
royal caribbean just unveiled a new
summer series of fully vaccinated cruise
and mediterranean
only one day after it announced a
different look collection of vaccine
mandated sailings from bermuda
vaccinated against covet 19 and craving
a warm summer escape a broader cruise
ship
royal caribbean's newly announced seven
night mediterranean cruises may be a
good fit for you
these new mediterranean sailings will
cruise with a vaccine mandate
this means all crew members and adult
guests abroad the ship
will have to be vaccinated against covet
19 while passengers under 18 years old
will instead have to test negative
for the virus however royal caribbean
notes that these protocols may change as
they are evaluated
on an ongoing basis thoughts well
we uh we were participants in a royal
caribbean cruise line a couple years ago
we went to mediterranean we went to uh
islands a beautiful trip
um i remember when covet first hit they
wouldn't let that uh
that cruise ship come aboard uh and as
much as
people were hesitant about jumping on a
plane will you trust
and physically trust your body in the in
a
cruise liner for seven days four days
five days where you're around everybody
you eat everywhere
you're together it's going to be
interesting how the social distance is
going to take place
especially around the buffet when it's
food time or times go show or time to
get
in line for onboarding onboarding uh
debarking process
i think they're just trying to get back
in business baby yeah they're just
trying to get back in business and one
way to do it is okay if you're all
vaccinated come on here we'll go on a
trip
because remember there were three crisis
at the beginning of cobit right
crisis number one what exactly is this
virus would we do about we just didn't
know the biological makeup of it
second crisis is what you know it's is
this it the wuhan food court
the what the what meat market or was it
you know a lab over there there was a
china conspiracy
and then the next big story was the
first
two before we were using the word super
spreader we had two cruise ships
that were basically stuck was it
they ended up in san francisco but they
were stuck in tokyo weren't they like
tokyo harbor the cruise ships at the
very beginning of covid
and cruise ships have never had a
reputation for being perfectly clean you
talk about the water and food poisoning
and things
like this so i think they're just trying
to get back in business and they're
saying this is why we're going to do it
i think it's that's something get some
revenue coming in
yeah the pritzker family owns it the
illinois governor
jim jimbo pritzker um 55th
richest man in the world the government
that family owns the uh royal caribbean
you know it's uh it's going to be
interesting travel i i think with
what we experienced just coming down
here to boca flying in fort lauderdale
just to see the explosion of
of rental cars and businesses and people
coming down here i think the same thing
potentially gonna happen here with
cruise line people
there's a the parties you were talking
about the person wants us to stay home
a person is okay around other people and
the third person says i'm fine just
being out and about they're ready to go
who has the most uh
influence the radical uh
who is like dude i don't really care
whether i wear a mask or not
the radical who is extremely paranoid
don't get near me don't touch me
you know this is we're being foolish
state of texas being irresponsible for
getting people to go back to work this
is not the right thing to do
or the people in the middle who are like
let's just tell me what the rules and
regulations are followed who has
the most more influence the most
influence for everybody to be scared
for their criticism of the other side
which of those three would you say it is
i think it's the one in the middle the
second one because they have the bigger
you know it's a broader base uh people
that aren't uh
you know they're okay with being amongst
other people and kind of let me know
what the rules are we'll follow
i think that's uh the folks with the
most influence what do you think
i think people started out scared and
then they were frustrated and now you
have vaccination that people think is a
panacea seal just let me remind
everybody we get vaccinated for the flu
every year because these viruses morph
you know they evolve um i think that the
seeing more people doing more normal
things with a vaccination
is a big peer pressure and raises and
drops people's guard to say
you know what honey we can go out now we
can go to dinner now i'm seeing more of
our friends do it they take a mass
they're very careful
but they're vaccinated and they're
getting back into it we can do that too
i think that's a very the pure around
you seeing them
to get back to normal that who has the
influence we all want
which of the groups have more influence
yeah uh i think the
the radical uh like don't care at all no
mask no crew
um i think those are obviously everyone
can look at them and call them the crazy
ones
uh so in a sense i think it's more the
not the middle but the
the hysterical ones that's kind of where
i'm at because they'll play the victim
card
scream scream the wolf so i definitely
think that and everybody's scared
nowadays walking on eggshells did you
see what this person said did you see
what that person said yeah exactly i
agree with you
who's doing that that's horrible yeah
because of xyz i agree with you derek so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye